we just found the most powerful things
we don't want that goblin dead - Sara
those repulsive a name
[Music]
thanks ta for sponsoring this video and
flying us out to their headquarters we
play Star Wars Battlefront 2 - where we
going today
San Francisco we're going to a corporate
business park straight outside of San
Francisco Redwood Shores we're going to
EA headquarters to play Star Wars
Battlefront 2 I'm pretty excited about
it
yes this time is your flight 7 fun fact
I was born in San Francisco even though
I see a Minnesota boy all the time I
lived it for like 6 years I have a very
special connection to the city
I'm also the San Francisco boy that's
cool that's actually I do know that
mission is we've got a few hours we have
a late start tomorrow at noon so that
means we have a late night to spend
doing whatever we want what do we want
to do what you want to do oh my god dude
San Francisco school hey hey you want to
put a cool ends on here you want to try
to cool ends dude it's that whacky
Russian lens
[Music]
we're starting a storyline here that's
right you're witnessing the beginning of
a storyline to start the story we have
to go back a few years we're talking
about the original battlefront games
this is like early 2000s here I'm still
like in middle school almost high school
here I literally just spent my high
school career imagining myself in the
next wing the issue with being in high
school and middle school is that you
don't have a steady job because there's
this thing called school that takes up
all your stupid times you don't have any
money it's you're stuck playing game
demos specifically game demos of the
first and second star wars battlefront
games I didn't even have an internet
connection on my computer I just
download these demos and play like
against bots could afford the game it
was painful and so we hit fast forward
on the clock all the way up till right
now we're en hey guys can we fly you up
to our headquarters to play the new Star
Wars Battlefront 2 video game and I'm
like yeah before we walk in though let's
see what we're getting into this is the
EA headquarters mind you I've heard a
lot of mixed things about it let me see
if there's any reviews they don't have a
Yelp page pretty decent place to work 5
stars
delicious food wait hold on good
location great food great times no joke
that's actually one of the reviews I do
know for sure that we are going to get
to place a multiplayer today which is
honestly what I'm really really excited
about because do you bring did you bring
your medals did I have them in my pocket
I'm not too competitive of a guy but I
think it's getting to Nick's head right
now because I got to keep my title right
I just want to say it was really nice of
EA to fly me out here I don't think it's
a competition I think I'm gonna take
home the gold how do we know if you've
won this promotional event what's up Sam
how you doing right we're going
[Music]
so what's our setup today what we're
doing right now is I'm doing
single-player and arcade mode so arcade
is kind of the sub placement matches you
guys can play like split-screen with
each other at some points too
[Music]
so dude I guess we play video games for
a living now works except oh you dude
you got to remember you're talking to
the 10 to the 10 gig shape this is the
10 gig should I introduce you listen oh
my god oh my god let's just do some
local split-screen stuff okay Kyle Adobe
one Kenobi Sam where are you
did you kill me yeah oh is that you with
the with the big mission yeah so do we
have an objective that we have to you
know we're together it's cool he'll your
troops kind of stay to your position a
little bit the squad here man yeah let's
me I want to give you a hug go to the
middle thing with the prison prison
tower no I got a little present for you
oh dude you kill me and then my grenade
guy yet oh is that you that I can show
you see us together see how we're lying
across from each other like that so
poetic
star war is hell star war is hell I mean
there's something undeniably fun about
being in Star War I think you're winning
holy cow so dude I'm so dude look how
tiny his he literally just jumps at your
throat and strangle - dude Yoda is so
yeah come and I get ya you're alive
oh is this it is this the death of Yoda
the Star Wars to the death
[Music]
[Laughter]
we just found the most powerful things
this whole social for something a lot
that goblin dead Dussehra those
repulsive a name
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay
I'm sorry I'm about to win dude dude
it's flowing through all the fates now
that you're in the end
[Music]
now you die killed at least you died
though at least hey how's it going I'm
Nick likewise we were playing as you I
don't know if you're doing it justice
though that's not how it's supposed to
end how was it doing a voice for a video
game character well this is performance
captain yeah yeah little jumpsuits and
stuff but but the thing is it's it's
clear as everyone's in a jumpsuit school
right but it really is exactly what you
would do on television or in film shows
except that's cool lacking the vanity
chip which I love very much right so you
don't just put a chair in the morning
waiting to make sure you look good or
what I mean that stuff's do the work and
the data will pick it up that is
actually that's actually I do a lot of
like productions and you know work
factors very frequently myself and I've
never heard that insight when it comes
to motion capture performance wise it's
some beautiful magic
area between what you would do on camera
and what you do in theater because there
are much more physical experience with
just like theater you don't have to
worry about stepping out of frame yeah
yeah and also it's one full tape right
so you can do it multiple times but it's
one full take all the way through so
when you're watching those cut scenes we
did it however many takes it took to get
it perfect well beginning to end well
it's it's more like theater and that
little hybrid and it's so nice that's
why theater actors thrive in motion
capture what was like a really
challenging scene that would normally be
easy on camera but really hard to do as
part of like motion capture any time you
have props or you have a really
participated moment you know
everything's great you're in a volume
you have to just use theater of the mind
yes yeah
so we just have these lines of tape and
if you step over and you forget don't
leap it you're in the pit guys you're in
you know so yeah yeah yeah we're
standing your environment really taking
a second to visualize what I'm stepping
into is really important we made a fan
film for service in high school oh my
god
oh yeah this is like in the year like
2004 oh it's so would you say no this is
adorable and nostalgic here we go
so we can't watch the whole thing cuz
it's a half hour long oh my god I'm so
funny
a long time ago in a galaxy far far away
this is like in the year 2000 when like
we were like literally just like kids in
my eighth grade trying to figure out
computer graphics this is so sweet
like from the year 2000 take this
that's me so do you think I have an
acute keeping either this shot and maybe
being in maybe battle
no thank you
oh we're on a farm
do you like those costumes I know yeah
we just cut right through the story get
all the bad out of it that's me yeah
that's Boba Fett we didn't have enough
money for costume we just so this is
like him on his off hours this is M
Heyman is like pajamas amazing track I
mean that's amazing
now look now we're in the real stuff
I don't let you guys keep playing but
it's so nice hanging out with you guys
take care I hope you love the game so
much my super cool things I'm a good
actor maybe I can be in the next Star
Wars Battlefront
[Music]
are you in the e gaming like I am you
have an e gaming chair because I do
I got a shout-out to my my share
sponsorship grandma grandma
grandma's gaming chairs secondhand ten
bucks at Goodwill right now we've been
playing a lot of multi player today Nick
is crushing it I'm not but it's still
really fun it's really I'm literally
sitting here at EA's headquarters
playing video games all day so all that
pent-up frustration that angst the
teenaged Sam Star Wars angst is like
just like coming out it's coming out and
it feels great